Prof: Okay,
as you may remember,
way back before the exam,
we'd started looking at how
things really happened,
how people were able to figure
out about bonds,
and how atoms were arranged,
and molecules reacted,
before there were the powerful
techniques that we --
that developed mostly in the
last twenty-five or thirty
years,
as far as their practical
application in organic
chemistry;
but how they found these out
before that time.
And it started with what we
call the "Chemical
Revolution",
which was launched by
Lavoisier, with this book,
in 1789, the same year as the
French Revolution,
The Elementary Treatise of
Chemistry.
Which, you remember,
he started work on just because
he was interested in improving
nomenclature,
but found that there was such a
tight coupling between
nomenclature and the science --
that is, the facts and the
theory --
that he couldn't improve any
one of them without improving
the others.
So we saw last time that he
developed a --
that in the process of
developing a new nomenclature,
he also developed instruments,
so that he could weigh gases,
because weighing turns out to
be such an important feature in
all of nineteenth century
chemistry,
no doubt the most important
single technique.
But he also could measure heat,
which didn't have any weight.
For that he developed a
calorimeter together with
Laplace, and we saw how that
worked by melting ice.
So now we're going to look at
some of the other developments
from this book,
in particular the idea of
oxidation.
There's no doubt that the most
important element for Lavoisier
was oxygen,
because of its key role in his
chemistry,
so that all other elements were
called bases,
or radicals. Right?
And they could react with
oxygen to become new things.
There were several degrees of
oxidation, as shown in this
table from the English
translation of his book.
So first you get an oxide,
oxides of all the elements that
are listed in the first table.
For example,
hydrogen when oxidized would
give water;
that's the second row.
But the first row is caloric.
This was sort of a stretch,
at least it seems so from our
perspective, that caloric,
heat, when it gets oxidized,
yields oxygen gas.
But then there were further
degrees of oxidation if you
reacted with more oxygen.
So the second degree of
oxidation, according to his
theory, was to give an acid,
that the suffix was to be
systematically o-u-s,
so -ous.
And those names we use now,
like cuprous,
ferrous, come directly from
this work of Lavoisier.
So that's the lower oxidation
state of an acid.
Right?
So you have,
for example,
nitrous acid,
carbonous acid,
sulfurous acid,
phosphorous acid,
he said.
And then you have a still
higher degree of oxidation,
the third degree,
which is the -ic acid.
So you have nitric acid,
carbonic acid,
sulfuric acid.
And notice that many of these
were not known;
and many of them still are not
known because the theory wasn't
exactly right.
For example,
carbonous acid was not known at
that time;
you see in the second entry in
the second row,
second column.
Okay?
And then there was still a
fourth degree of oxidation,
which he called the
oxygenated ic acid.
He didn't use the peroxy acid,
as we would often use nowadays.
But he used,
for example,
oxygenated nitric acid,
which was unknown.
Oxygenated carbonic acid was
unknown.
Same for sulfuric or phosphoric.
And oxygenated muriatic acid
was -- used to be called
dephlogisticated marine acid.
But he has a more systematic
name, showing its degree of
oxidation.
So these -ous and
-ic names,
that we still use,
come directly from Lavoisier.
And probably the next most
important tool he developed was
one for doing elemental
analysis.
Remember, you could do
proximate analysis,
what other compounds are
present in the substance you're
studying.
Or you could do ultimate
analysis and find out how much
of the elements there was in
each.
And this was how to do
elemental analysis of an organic
oil.
So it has carbon,
hydrogen, oxygen in it.
Okay?
So this big upside-down barrel,
inside another barrel with
water in it,
is how he got air for the
burning, because the upside-down
barrel would be lowered into the
water,
which would create pressure in
the oxygen that's trapped
inside.
It would then flow out through
the pipe you see coming from the
tank,
through a dryer and into this
big, vertical cylinder where the
combustion takes place,
fed by an oil supply which is
siphoned in as needed.
So there's a lamp inside,
burning the oil with the air,
and the vapors generated by the
combustion come up and out the
tube to the right.
So there's the lamp.
The gases come out and water
gets condensed in the spiral
tube, in here,
and drips down and gets
collected in the jar that you
see.
And the part that doesn't
condense and get collected into
the jar,
gets absorbed in that
horizontal tube that has a
calcium chloride drying agent in
it.
So at the end of the experiment
you weigh how much water there
is in the jar and how much the
calcium chloride has increased
in weight,
and that tells you how much
water there was.
And what does that tell you
about the compound?
How much what?
What element is being measured
in the oil, by weighing the
water?
It's measuring the hydrogen.
So he had to know what percent,
by weight, water is,
of hydrogen.
Then if he measured the water
that came from combustion,
he measured how much hydrogen
there was in the oil sample that
was being burned.
And then the gases continued to
go through limewater,
calcium hydroxide.
So that would absorb CO_2,
as calcium carbonate.
So those would increase in mass.
And he had two of them,
so whatever got through the
first one would hopefully be
collected in the next one.
And then there's another drying
tube, on further from that,
because these solutions,
as you pass gas over them,
they lose a little bit of their
water.
Right?
So they'd be losing weight,
as well as gaining weight from
the CO_2 that's being absorbed.
Right?
But that water that's lost is
reabsorbed in that final tube.
So you weigh it at the end,
and now you have --
you've corrected for whatever
loss of water there was from the
bulbs,
and now you know what weight of
CO_2.
And if know what fraction of
CO_2 is carbon -- and there's a
homework problem for Friday that
you can look at.
You can work in groups on that,
that shows you how he knew how
much -- what weight percentage
of CO_2 was carbon.
So having then measured how
much CO_2, he knew how much
carbon there was in the oil.
So he measured the hydrogen,
he measured the carbon.
So that's fine if it's a
hydrocarbon oil.
How about if there was oxygen
in the oil?
Notice, he's adding all kinds
of oxygen from the air.
So how's he going to know how
much oxygen there was,
if it was an alcohol or
something that he was burning?
Student:
>
Prof: Sam?
Can't hear you.
Student:  The leftovers.
Prof: It's the leftovers.
You see how much oil got
burned, how much carbon,
how much hydrogen,
and you assume there's nothing
else there, except oxygen.
So you get oxygen by difference.
And that's the way oxygen is
almost always measured,
is by difference.
Right?
So you assume -- and you have
to be sure there are no other
elements there,
if you want that to be true,
obviously.
Okay, so this was a big
operation and it took,
you know, somebody to control
the air supply to make sure it
was constant.
Notice, incidentally,
there's a T here.
So there was another one of
these things over here,
another one of these double
barrels.
Right?
Why?
Student:
>
Prof: Ah,
so when you run out of air in
one, you switch the valve and
take it from the other one;
then you can go back to the
first one.
So you have an infinite supply
of air, plenty to burn the oil.
Right?
But you need someone to control
that,
and you need someone else to
make sure the lamp stays lit,
that it gets the proper amount
of oil siphoned in,
and the airflow is right.
You need someone else -- in the
CO_2 collectors,
you just blow gas over the
surface.
Right?
So it's got a little key on the
top and a hook that goes down
in.
Somebody has to be standing
there, doing this,
to keep it stirred.
Right?
So that's stirred.
So it takes at least three or
four people to run this thing.
Right?
And it cost a lot of money to
build.
So no one else built one.
In fact, it's not absolutely
certain that Lavoisier ever used
this, although it exists --
right?
-- because he was busy with
other things,
having to do with the French
Revolution, by the time this
came along.
But this was big science. Right?
He was very wealthy,
so he was able to do this kind
of thing.
But he showed,
in this diagram,
exactly how it could be done.
So it was no secret,
not like what the alchemists
did.
Was there a question here?
No.
Yes Lucas?
Student:  Did they ever
measure like the air supply they
gave it?
Prof: Did they measure
--
Student:  Did they
measure the amount of air that
they gave into it?
Did they know like the amount
of the air?
Prof: I don't think so,
because there wasn't any
purpose;
you didn't care how much air
you put in.
Because most of the air just
flowed right on through,
it was never collected.
Right?
It just carried the other gases
along, where the water and the
CO_2 would be collected.
Student:  Well I guess
if they knew the content of the
air, like they could just
measure how much oxygen-
Prof: To get the oxygen?
Conceivably;
but that was never done.
It would've been very difficult
to collect all that air and
measure it accurately.
Okay now what if you have a
substance that won't burn
cleanly, so you can't measure
these gases?
Notice, incidentally,
the role of gases in
understanding things,
because they provide easy
separation.
Right?
And then since he was able to
weigh gas, once,
then he knows the gas density.
So now all you have to do,
from then on,
in principle,
is measure the volume of gas,
and you know how much stuff
there was.
So gases played a really key
role through all this.
But suppose you had a substance
that wouldn't burn,
that you couldn't convert to
steam and CO_2.
What do you do then?
For example, grape sugar.
So here's chapter thirteen
where he talks about le suc
des raisins,
the grape sugar;
which will char,
it won't burn cleanly.
So what do you do?
Well, as he says up at the top
there, "tout le monde
sait comment se fait le
vin";
everyone knows how to make
wine, cider and mead.
Right?
So can you see what he's going
to do?
So here's the device for that
one, which is in many ways sort
of similar, but you don't need
an air -- you don't put the air
in.
What you have is a big flask at
the beginning which has sugar,
yeast and water.
Right?
So the yeast ferments the sugar
and changes it into CO_2.
So you have -- it foams up;
if you've even seen something
fermenting.
So you have to have something
that catches the foam so it
won't get into your device.
And then you have something
that will absorb water.
Now the water is not just --
it's not like the previous one,
where the water is all formed
by the thing,
because you got a whole bunch
of water there at the beginning.
Right?
So that's not what you're
trying to measure.
What you're trying to measure
is how much carbon,
how much CO_2 there is in the
grape sugar.
So you have these sodium
hydroxide solutions,
the base that will absorb the
CO_2, as a carbonate.
So you weigh those before and
after.
And the excess gas,
if there's another gas being
evolved, will collect over the
mercury in the far tube here.
So he could measure the CO --
the carbon, in sugar,
by converting it completely to
CO_2 through fermentation.
In speaking of fermentation
here, he says it furnishes a
means of analyzing sugar.
So oxidation failed with air.
Even with oxygen or sulfuric
acid or mercuric oxide,
you couldn't get clean
combustion of sugar;
you got charring instead.
But as he says here -- this is
the most interesting thing about
his treatment of the data --
he said, "I could consider
the materials subjected to
fermentation,
and the products of
as an algebraic equation,
having to do with weights."
Can you see what his
assumption's going to be here?
Student:
>
Prof: Sam?
Student:  The same
weights on both --
Prof: The same weights
on both side;
conservation of mass is his
assumption.
Okay?
So he can make an equation that
the weight on the right and the
weight on the left will be the
same.
Okay, so an algebraic equation.
"And by in turn,
supposing each of the elements
of the equation to be unknown,
I can derive a value,
and thus correct experiment by
calculation,
and calculation by
experiment."
So what does he mean by that?
So if you have this equation,
a certain amount of sugar and a
certain amount of oxygen gives a
certain amount of CO_2,
for example.
Right?
So the weights on the two sides
should be the same.
He doesn't know one of them.
Right?
But if he knows all the others,
and it's an algebraic equation,
he can then solve for that one.
So he says here:
"I can derive a value and
thus correct experiment by
calculation."
Have you ever heard of that
being done?
Lexie?
Student:
>
Prof: Would somebody --
would you do that in lab,
correct experiment?
Do you suppose there might be
any nefarious people who would
correct their experiments by
calculation after finishing a
lab?
Student:
>
Prof: No,
I can't imagine that would
happen, right?
Okay, but Lavoisier was
upfront.
Right?
He was even,
one might say,
bragging about it,
that he has this algebraic
equation, so he can correct his
experiments.
Right?
"I've often profited from
this way of correcting the
preliminary results of my
experiments."
No one told him that that's not
the way science works.
Right?
That the experiments are the
things you have to do.
You have to adjust the theory
to deal with the experiments.
Okay?
Remember, he was the treasurer
for the firm that collected
taxes for the French Crown.
Right?
So he was accustomed to
bookkeeping, and everything had
to balance, right down to the
sou.
Right?
So the same thing he applied to
chemistry.
So Table One here is the
materials of fermentation.
He put in a certain amount of
water, 400 pounds;
a certain amount of sugar,
100 pounds; yeast.
Now he knew that the yeast was
wet.
So there was a certain amount
of water.
He put ten pounds of yeast,
but he knew by analysis,
by proximate analysis -- right?
-- not what the elements are
but what the substances are
there --
that in ten pounds of yeast,
wet yeast,
you'd have seven pounds,
three ounces,
six gros and forty-four grains.
It turns that a gros is a 72nd
of a grain, and eight gros make
an ounce.
So it's a gros is -- which is
28.35 grams.
So, if you want,
you can work through all this.
Do you think he had analyzed
things that accurately,
that he knew right down to the
gros how much there was in
there?
No.
There's no way he could've
known that.
But things had to balance,
right?
So he made an approximate
thing, and then he carried it
out to eighteen decimal points,
the way you'd do on a
calculator.
Right?
Okay, so he didn't know about
significant figures yet either.
Okay?
So then in Table Two he figures
in that much water,
sugar, yeast,
how much is there of --
in each one,
how much is in water,
how much is hydrogen,
and how much is oxygen.
So he knows that.
So now he knows down to
hundredths of gros how much of
each of those elements there are
in the 400 pounds of water he's
using.
Incidentally,
he never used 400 pounds of
water.
He just rounded his numbers up,
or multiplied his numbers,
scaled them up to be that big.
He used large quantities,
but not that large.
Okay.
So if you had 100 pounds of
sugar, you'd have a certain
amount of hydrogen,
oxygen and charcoal - that is,
carbon.
And if you had a certain amount
of the dry yeast you'd have
that.
And then he makes still a third
table where he rearranges it,
so he pulls the elements all
together.
So in the starting material,
how much hydrogen,
oxygen and carbon?
Okay?
So he's got 411 pounds,
12 ounces, 6 gros,
1.36 grains of oxygen -- grains
and gros, got it;
oh gros and grains,
okay, right -- okay,
that much oxygen and some
amount of hydrogen and charcoal,
and a certain amount of
nitrogen that's in the yeast,
because he knew that was there;
which is just a small weight
altogether, because there's not
much yeast.
And in all, 510 pounds exactly.
Right?
So his balance sheet was just
like what a banker would want.
Okay, and now he does -- he
looks at the products,
and he has a certain amount of
CO_2 that he collected;
that's carbonic acid.
And he knows how much oxygen
and charcoal;
there is that.
A certain amount of water.
A certain amount of alcohol,
if dry.
So he had to collect the
alcohol and say how much alcohol
and how much water was in it.
How much acetic acid.
How much residual sugar that
had fermented.
And how much dry yeast there
was at the end.
And he added them all together,
and by God, there was 510
pounds, zero ounces,
zero gros, and zero grains.
Right?
QED.
Okay?
And then he recapitulated it,
according to how much oxygen,
how much charcoal and how much
hydrogen.
And once again it balances out
absolutely precisely.
Okay, so he recapitulates it
that way.
And this is how he would do
some of these things.
Okay?
So this is a description of an
experiment,
on page eighty-eight to
ninety-two of the
Traité
Élémentaire.
Okay, so he's got a fire
burning here,
and a glass tube that runs
through the middle of the
charcoal that's burning.
Right?
And he's got a flask cemented
to it, on the right,
which is over a burner.
And in the tube he puts
twenty-eight grains of carbon --
not pieces but a weight of
twenty-two grains.
We saw what a grain was last
time.
That turns out to be 1.38 grams
of carbon he's got inside the
tube.
Okay, and now do you think the
carbon will evaporate,
incidentally,
if you put it in flame?
Do you know how?
How do you know it won't
evaporate?
Student:  It shouldn't.
Prof: Where do you get
carbon?
What did he call it?
Student:  Charcoal.
Prof: He called it
charcoal.
You get charcoal by the flame,
right?;
so with burning without enough
oxygen.
So obviously it's not going to
evaporate, it's just going to
sit there.
Okay, so in flask A there he
puts water.
So there's water in it.
And then he lights the fire
underneath and the water begins
to boil, and distills through
the tube and collects over here
in H. Right?
There it comes.
Okay?
But did you notice what
happened in the process?
Want me to back up and do it
again?
What happened?
Student:  The charcoal
went away.
Prof: The charcoal went
away.
What happened?
Well let's see what he found.
So, the twenty-eight grains of
carbon was gone.
Right?
And in the end he got the water
that he had put in at the start,
but not all the water.
It was 85.7 grains short.
So all the carbon and some of
the water has gone.
Where did it go?
Well it went out the tube.
So out the tube,
he said, came 144 cubic inches
--
and because he knows the
density, he knows how much
weight that is --
100 grains, exactly,
of carbonic gas,
CO_2;
we would call it CO_2 -- and
380 cubic inches of flammable
gas.
So one of them would be
collected by limewater,
the carbonic gas,
and the other one would go
right on through.
What do you suppose flammable
gas is?
Students:  Hydrogen.
Prof: Hydrogen.
So the oxygen went to the
carbon, and the hydrogen became
elemental hydrogen,
in this process.
Okay?
Now, look at this,
this is what's neat.
So he got 100 grams -- 100
grains, pardon me,
of carbonic gas,
and 13.7 grains of hydro-gen,
the stuff that gives water when
you burn it,
according to him. Right?
Which is right,
which is correct.
And what do you notice,
quantitatively?
Student:  They match.
Prof: They exactly
match, right down to the 10ths
of grains.
Okay?
Now, if you recalculate,
by modern theory,
how much gas you should get
from twenty-eight grains of
carbon doing this,
you should get 157 cubic inches
and 313 cubic inches,
instead of 144 and 380;
you should get 103 grains of
carbonic gas and 9.4 grains of
flammable gas.
So his experiments weren't
perfect.
Right?
Which is not surprising,
and there's no shame in that.
But what would we now say he
did wrong?
Student:  He adjusted
his results.
Prof: He adjusted his
results to fit his theory.
Okay?
But this was early days.
He thought, he actually said,
on page ninety-two:
"I have thought it best to
correct by calculation and to
present the experiment in all
its simplicity."
Now what's wrong with
presenting an experiment in all
its simplicity?
You lose anything that's new,
anything that you might have
discovered in the experiment.
Okay?
But he was discovering a lot of
stuff, so we'll forgive him
that.
Okay?
He was certainly a great
scientist.
So what were his contributions?
Clarity, above all. Right?
This idea of facts and ideas
and words having to go together
and improve together.
And of the facts he worked on,
there were these -- the
apparatus I showed,
and others as well.
The important thing was
quantitation,
using numbers,
which people hadn't used before
--
not nearly as effectively at
least --
concentrating on making things
balance,
using mass as the criterion for
how much stuff you have.
But also, in the case of gases,
volume, but measuring the
density, so that you can relate
volume to mass,
which is the fundamental
quantity.
He found some new substances --
although that wasn't much of a
contribution on his part;
other people,
like Scheele before him,
had discovered lots and lots of
new pure substances;
that wasn't Lavoisier's strong
suit -- and reactions.
And then, with respect to
ideas, the idea of what an
element is;
that it's not some platonic
ideal, but it only means as far
as we've so far been able to go
in analyzing things and breaking
them down.
And if we can't break them down
further, we'll assume for the
time-being that they are
elements, but maybe that they
won't be in the long run.
The idea of conservation of
mass, of course,
is key.
Oxidation as the organizing
principle.
The idea of a radical,
that an element is the base of
something and that it can become
an acid through oxidation.
And the idea of salts,
from mixing of elements.
And with respect to words,
the idea that names should be
meaningful;
in particular,
the names for elements,
oxidation state.
So he developed these suffixes;
-ous, -ic, -ide,
-ite and -ate are all due to
Lavoisier.
And the idea of a salt
composition, the way of naming
them, that sodium hydrox-ide,
for example,
or sodium chlor-ide,
or chlor-ate,
or chlor-ite;
which are different degrees of
oxidation of the element.
But, like everyone who would
follow, and everyone before,
and everyone nowadays,
he was plagued by lack of
imagination.
Right?
That's always the short suit of
everyone who's in science,
or probably in anything.
He said, at the end of this
preface that we've talked about:
"Chemistry's present
progress,
however, is so rapid,
and the facts,
under modern doctrine,
have assumed so happy an
arrangement,
that we have ground to hope,
even in our own times,
to see it approach near to the
highest state of perfection of
which it is susceptible."
Right?
So people always think that;
that there are a few things you
see you have to do to fill in
little chinks here and there,
but otherwise we've got it now.
Right?
This is certainly what a lot of
people tended to think about the
human genome.
Once you know what the human
genome is, then all diseases are
solved, everything else.
Right?
It's never been true and it
almost certainly is not true
now.
And it certainly wasn't true in
his time.
He said, "even in our own
times."
He wrote this in 1789,
and in 1794 he was guillotined.
>
So it certainly didn't happen
in his own time.
The judge, Coffinhal,
is reported to have said,
although perhaps apocryphally,
that "the Republic has no
need of geniuses."
And, in fact,
all his equipment was seized
for The People,
including his 80 pounds of
mercury that he carried around
in this thing,
to measure gases.
That madness lasted only a
couple of years;
maybe not even that long.
And his widow recovered the
equipment, and it currently is
in the Musée des Arts et
Métiers in Paris.
I've never seen it,
but a number of students from
the class have sent me postcards
when they've gone to see it.
Okay, and Lagrange,
the guy that helped him build
the calorimeter,
wrote: "It took them only
an instant to make this head
fall,
but 100 years may not suffice
to reproduce one like it."
So what we're going to look at
is what the heads in the next
100 years were able to
accomplish.
So today we're going to do the
first twenty,
or twenty-five,
or thirty years after
Lavoisier, to see where things
went.
So we've looked at Boyle and
his gas laws,
and Lavoisier.
And now we're going to go on to
Dalton.
So here's John Dalton,
who lived up near the Lake
District in England.
And he was an amateur
meteorologist.
So he was interested in keeping
weather records and so on.
And in particular he was
interested in why,
in the atmosphere,
if you collect air at the top
of a mountain,
and down in the bottom of a
valley,
you get the same composition.
Why don't the heavier gases
sink and the lighter ones rise?
Good question, right?
Well people on the continent
had proposed that different
gases attract one another.
So they tend to stick and
therefore stay mixed.
Right?
But Dalton had a different idea.
And this is a picture he drew
of gases.
The top is Azote,
or nitrogen,
and the bottom is hydrogen.
So he said, "The atoms of
one kind did not repel the atoms
of another kind."
It's not -- well you'll see in
just a second.
Okay, so the center is his
symbol for the atom;
nitrogen in that case.
And surrounding it,
this sort of halo,
is the "envelope"
that's heat associated with
that particular atom.
So these rays come out.
And if the rays meet one
another, between adjacent atoms
in the gas, then they repel one
another;
according to Dalton's theory.
But if they don't match,
as in hydrogen and nitrogen,
then they don't repel one
another.
Right?
So atoms of the same element
tend to stay apart,
but atoms of the other element
are completely free to be inside
there.
They knew that the pressure
went down, as you went up;
that was no question, right?
But why don't they stratify?
It's because the different
elements don't repel one
another.
So he substituted
homorepulsion,
that the same atoms repel one
another, for what the Europeans
used as heteroattraction.
Okay?
Obviously that turned out to be
nonsense.
But Dalton developed three
principles, in terms of these
atoms that he had started using
for this purpose of something
about the atmosphere.
These principles have come to
be known as Definite
Proportions, Equivalent
Proportions, and Multiple
Proportions.
So Definite Proportions is that
pure compounds always have the
same weight ratio of their
elements.
So you don't get a sample,
of sugar here,
that's a certain percentage of
carbon and hydrogen,
and a slightly different
percentage of carbon and
hydrogen here.
And he explains it by saying
that these compounds are a given
ratio of elements.
So you have that same ratio all
the time when you have a
particular compound.
Now Equivalent Proportions is a
pretty simple idea,
but it looks complex.
Okay, so suppose you have a
certain weight of A reacts with
a certain weight of B;
okay, to form AB.
Okay?
And a certain amount of A
reacts with a certain amount of
C, to form AC.
But if it's the same amount of
A, then in some sense that
weight of B and that weight of C
are equivalent to one another.
Okay?
Because they react with the
same weight of A;
so they're equivalent.
But now suppose you have
another compound D that also
reacts with b parts of B.
A reacted with b parts
of B. Right?
What does that tell you,
about equivalence?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: That means that
a parts of A is
equivalent to d parts of
D.
Okay?
So just suppose two grams of A
reacted with three grams of B,
and two grams of A reacted with
eight grams of C.
That means three grams of B is
equal to eight grams of C,
for purposes of combining.
Okay?
And suppose 1.5 grams of D also
reacted with three grams of B.
Then 1.5 grams of D is equal to
one gram of A.
Okay?
Now what could you conclude?
What's the final line going to
be?
What do you predict from this,
if you have these kinds of
equivalence;
an equivalence between B and C
and an equivalence between A and
B?
Can you see?
Then you predict that if you
react D and C,
what's going to happen?
What weight ratio will they be
in?
Student:  d parts
of --
Prof: Okay,
d parts of D will react
with c parts of
C.***Right?
Because the D is like the A in
the beginning.
The C is like the B in the
beginning.
So d parts of D should
react with c parts of C.
That's what multiple
Proportions is.
I'll show you an example.
Okay?
And finally Multiple
Proportions.
If the same two elements form
several different compounds,
the weight ratios are related
by simple factors.
And I'll show you an example of
that.
So these are all things that
Dalton adduced as support for
the idea that things were made
of atoms, fundamental units.
Now Definite Proportions.
Does the same compound always
have the same ratio of the
elements in it?
The French School was divided
on this question.
Berthollet said,
"Non!"
Because he said they're metal
alloys, or natural
"organic"
materials that vary in their
analysis.
Right?
Okay?
And Proust said,
"Oui!"
Right?
And that defined
what chemistry was;
that chemists then began to
deal only with things that
obeyed this Law of Multiple
Proportions.
They didn't deal in fundamental
ways with alloys or with
complicated big molecules that
had really complicated formulas,
or couldn't be separated as
mixtures and therefore got
different analyses at different
times.
They assumed that anything that
was pure had this -- obeyed the
Law of Definite Proportions.
So it was really more of a
definition, than a law.
Okay, now Multiple Proportions.
So there were oxides of carbon;
you remember Lavoisier,
1789, defined 44% carbon and
56% oxygen in CO_2.
And again there are problems
for you to work together to see
how he did some of these things.
So that's one of them,
I believe.
And then in 1801 carbonic acid,
as it was called,
was analyzed and found to be
twenty-one grams of carbon to
seventy-two grams of oxygen.
Okay?
Or in the case of nitrogen,
there were several oxides that
had these ratios,
all as analyzed in 1810.
Right?
Now, you can look at the weight
ratios, if you want to.
Oxygen to carbon ratio in the
first one is 1.27,
the other is 2.57.
Or you can look in the oxides
of nitrogen, and they're
0.58,1.27,2.39.
Right?
Now, what do you notice about
these?
Do you learn anything from this?
These guys got these results
and sat down and scratched their
heads.
What did they come up with?
Anything profound?
Any relationships among these
numbers, that you can see?
Or are they just sort of random
numbers?
Yes.
Nick?
Student:  The ratio is
kind of like --
Prof: Can you speak up a
little bit?
Student:  1.27 is half
of --
Prof: Ah,
1.27 is very close to half of
2.57.
It's not exact,
but there's going to be
experimental error.
Right?
It's about one to two;
it's actually 2.02.
And if you look in the case of
nitrogen, it's 1:2:4.
Right?
It's actually 2.19 and 4.12.
So as always,
when people develop things
experimentally and observe
regularities,
there's a question of what's
real and what's just
experimental error;
and you have no way of knowing
at the beginning.
We have a way of knowing now
because we know what the true
weights are.
So they're integral values
consistent with simple atomic
ratios.
So now we know what the percent
errors were in these things.
Okay, that the ratio of the
error was about 5% or 4% off
from what it should've been in
the oxygen:nitrogen.
One is minus 2%,
the others are plus 11%.
So within roughly 5% or so,
they were doing a pretty job of
the analysis.
But they were able to see
through to this Law of Multiple
Proportions.
And that's what you would
expect, if these things were
made up of identical molecules
with simple ratios of numbers of
atoms in them.
So this tended to support
Dalton's ideas of atoms.
Okay, so we've looked at
Lavoisier.
And now we're on further into
elemental analysis,
doing accurate elemental
analysis, and the idea of atoms
and dualism.
And we'll see what that is
right away.
And to do that we're going to
focus on Berzelius,
but also talk about Gay-Lussac.
Okay, so there's Faraday,
whom we've talked about
already;
Berzelius and Gay-Lussac,
and also Davy,
in England.
Okay, so here's Berzelius in
Sweden.
Born in 1779.
Notice on the previous slide,
all those guys were born within
a year, 1778,1779.
Another guy that was born at
the same time didn't make it to
the list, but his statue is
right below, who's Benjamin
Silliman;
he was exactly the same time.
Okay, so here's Berzelius,
who lived to be almost seventy
years old, and did an awful lot
of stuff.
So he was very good at
analysis, both of organic
substances and of minerals.
In a period of six years he
accurately analyzed 2000
compounds for their elements.
Okay?
He developed really good atomic
weights.
Remember, we just saw that
these previous ones were off by
as much as 10 or 11%,
but he got very good ones for
fifty different elements.
Okay?
He studied electrolysis,
which we will see,
and used that to develop the
theory of dualism and how --
understanding reactions as
double decompositions;
and we'll shortly see what that
is.
And he did a lot of teaching
and writing.
He was the most respected
chemist worldwide.
He chose in his picture --
remember,
when these people got these
pictures painted,
they always chose some emblem
to put in,
and he chose his textbook that
he wrote in 1803 .
But he was a very important
editor and summarizer of the
year's progress in chemistry
every year.
And he developed the notation
that we still use for
composition.
So you'll see that.
Okay, notation for composition.
We're going to look at its
evolution, from alchemy through
Dalton to Berzelius,
which is what we use,
almost exactly.
Okay, so in 1774,
this is a table printed in
Sweden of symbols for elements
and compounds.
And you see,
for example,
here's vitriolum cupri,
or vitriolum coeruleum.
Do you know what about
cupri;
that's the symbol there of
copper, right?
So why would it have been
called coeruleum?
Can you see any word that's
related to that?
Student:  Cerulean.
Prof: What's cerulean
about it?
Student:  The color.
Prof: I got some here.
That's not it.
This is it.
It's cerulean, right?
Like the sky.
Okay.
Or iron, there's the alchemical
symbol of iron.
Or and vitriol means
sulfate, right?;
or mercury sulfate;
okay, lead.
Okay?
So these are the chemical
symbols.
Notice particularly
nitrum,
at the top, that comes from
nitrates.
Okay, and we'll focus on that
and see that that's exactly the
same symbol that Dalton used for
nitrogen.
So he derived his symbols for
atoms from the alchemical
symbols;
at least many of them.
Not all of them.
Here are some others.
And here are the symbols that
Berzelius used for the same
elements, which you see are the
ones we use now.
Okay?
So notice as -- so there were
alchemical symbols at the
beginning for Dalton,
as you went across,
but in the next row,
once you get to iron,
which is Fe in Berzelius,
can you see what it is?
It's a little hard to read at
this resolution.
It's a little circle with a
letter inside.
What's the letter for iron?
Can you see it?
It's in the middle of the
second row.
It's an 'I'.
I'm sorry it's not such a good
resolution.
And the next one is Z and then
C and the L.
Why?
Z?
Student:  Zinc.
Prof: Zinc.
C?
Student:  Copper.
Prof: Copper.
L?
Student:  Lead.
Prof: Lead.
And so on.
Okay, now down below that are
binary symbols.
So you put two elements
together, like H with O,
H with N, N with O,
H with C, O with C.
Now here's Dalton's logic about
these symbols.
He says, "When only one
combination of two bodies can be
obtained, it must be presumed to
be a binary one."
That is, if you get only one
compound, it must be one atom of
one and one atom of the other.
Right?
So what would water be?
Student:  H.
Prof: HO,
or his circle with a dot in the
circle.
Right?
"Unless some other cause
appear to the contrary"
that would show you that that's
not what you should assume.
Okay, the next row,
the ternary ones:
N2O, NO2, CO2,
CH2.
And what he said about that is:
"When two combinations are
observed,
of the same elements,
then they must be presumed to
be a binary and a ternary."
So you could have NO and NO2.
What if there are three
combinations of the same
elements that give compounds?
Do you see what he's going to
observe, what he's going to
suppose?
Student:  Binary.
Prof: Right?
"When three…
a binary, and the other two
ternary."
Okay?
Okay, and what about if there
are four?
"When four…
one binary, two ternary,
and one quaternary."
Okay?
So he's laying down rules of
logic for what,
the way atoms must behave.
And it turns out,
as we know, atoms have
different ideas from Dalton's
logic.
There's nothing illogical about
Dalton, it's just wrong.
Okay, and this is Berzelius's
notation for the same symbols
that Dalton gave on the left.
But you notice they're
completely recognizable to them,
except for one thing.
What's different?
Student: Superscripts
instead of subscripts.
Prof: Here was ours,
and here is Berzelius's.
The only difference is he used
superscripts instead of
subscripts.
Okay?
And he decided to base the
names on Latin,
so it would be international,
whereas Dalton had used
English.
And the formulas,
notice, are not structural.
Berzelius's aren't,
they're just written in a line
and the number.
These could've been assumed to
be structural,
that you thought the atoms were
arranged that way.
I don't know that Dalton really
had that idea,
but they sort of convey that
idea.
But Berzelius's don't,
they're just a list of the
elements and the ratio,
by weight, of atoms in them.
And he developed some more
fancy abbreviations as well,
where, for example,
these little dots above
elements would who show how much
oxygen was associated with it.
So that chromate
potassique was K with an O,
and chromium with three Os.
Or down here he has some even
fancier things.
Notice the superscripts denote
the number of atoms.
And this benzoic acid should be
H_10C_14O_3.
Now wait a second,
a carboxylic acid has how many
oxygens?
Carboxylate group?
Students:  Two.
Prof: Two.
Here he's got three.
The reason is that he felt
there was water in these acids.
So he heated the heck out of
them to drive the water out,
and what you actually were left
with was the anhydride.
So two acids had come together
and lost water.
Right?
So the formula should be
C_10C_14O_3, and he's got
H_12C_15.
So not so far off.
And he's got these neat symbols
for acetic, tartaric,
citric and so on,
acid.
But those didn't catch on
either.
But his symbols for the
elements did.
Now let's see what we got here,
I had one more topic.
Atomic weights and equivalents.
Okay, these are Dalton's atomic
weights that he used in 1808:
hydrogen one,
carbon five,
nitrogen five,
oxygen seven,
and so on.
Now as of 2004,
this is what they should've
been.
What's wrong with Dalton?
Why is he off so far,
for example,
in oxygen, which should be
sixteen, and he has seven?
How can he be off that much?
Charles?
Can't hear.
Student:  Diatomic.
Prof: Yeah,
what did he think water was?
Student:  HO.
Prof: HO.
We know it's H_2O.
So the ratio is off by a factor
of two.
Right?
So all these are off -- most of
these are off by a factor of two
or three, depending on what the
true formula we now know to be.
Okay?
But if you make that
correction, this is what kind of
errors he had in his atomic
weights.
There were roughly 10% or so
errors.
Right?
And the question in silicon
chloride.
Thomas Thomson in Scotland
thought it was SiCl.
Gmelin in Germany thought it
was SiCl_2.
Berzelius thought it was
SiCl_3_ and Odling in
England thought it was SiCl_4.
So you could have anything you
wanted.
Right?
So which one is it?
How can you tell which one it
is?
That's the problem.
Okay, this is when Gay-Lussac
in France gets into the act.
So in 1804, he and the
physicist Biot made a balloon
ascent to a height of 7000
meters.
That's way the heck up there.
And in fact,
that was a record for fifty
years.
And they have a big flask
they're carrying.
Why?
What do they want to do with
their big flask?
Student:  The flask was
to collect air.
Prof: Collect air at
7000 meters and see if it's
different.
Okay?
Okay, so they established that
the atmospheric composition is
invariant with altitude;
at least at the heights they
could do.
But that's not the most
important thing he did,
for our purpose.
One of the really important
things he did was figure out how
to oxidize sugar,
how to burn sugar cleanly.
Remember, Lavoisier had to
resort to fermentation.
But he found if the source of
the oxidation was sodium
chlorate,
then you could heat them
together and actually get it
right and get water and
CO_2_ out of sugar.
So that was a very important
practical contribution.
For the present purposes,
he found that when you
decompose water you get,
to one volume of oxygen you get
1.9989 volumes of hydrogen.
And if you do the same thing
with ammonia,
for a volume of nitrogen you
get 3.08163 volumes of hydrogen,
in his experiment.
What did he conclude?
What was Gay-Lussac's
conclusion for this?
Student:  H2.
Prof: What do you think
he thought the values would've
been if there was no
experimental error?
How much hydrogen would he have
gotten?
Student:  Two.
Prof: Two.
And how much hydrogen would he
have gotten from nitrogen?
Student:  Three.
Prof: Three. Right?
They're very,
very close, just a few percent
off.
Right?
And even closer in the case of
water.
So what did he think?
He thought the number,
that the volume of a gas was
proportional to the number of
atoms in it.
Right?
Whose name do you associate
that with?
Student: Avogadro.
Prof: Avogadro.
But both of them did it,
independently,
and Gay-Lussac is the one whose
data I'm showing here.
Okay, so this was an
alternative to Dalton's Law of
Greatest Simplicity.
Dalton said if there's only one
compound, it must be one to one.
Gay-Lussac said look at the gas
ratios.
And that turned out to be
correct;
although it didn't get
completely adopted for another
sixty years.
That's really funny.
Okay, that's enough for now.